Hi, I'm Vivek Kinra from the IBM
Cloud Hyper Protect Services team.
Today, we're going to talk about Confidential
Computing as provided by Hyper Protect.
So, why Confidential Computing?
Data security and protection are by far
the biggest inhibitors for organizations
seeking to move sensitive applications
and data to the public cloud.
In fact, 95% of our customers
in regulated industry cited security, privacy,
regulatory concerns and cloud provider having a
backdoor access to organizations sensitive data as
their main inhibitors for using a public cloud.
To address these concerns, we are talking
about three pillars of data security
when considering end-to-end data protection.
Data at rest and data in flight are the two
pillars that historically have received the
most attention and addresses many concerns.
However, when regulated industries clients
bring their sensitive workloads to the IBM Cloud
Hyper Protect Services, they want
to process their sensitive data with
highest level of data protection without
compromising the performance and latency.
So, to complete the data protection
lifecycle, client wants to protect
their data when it in use, or in memory.
This is the focus of confidential computing.
The IBM Cloud Hyper Protect Services, including
Crypto Services, Virtual Servers and DBaaS offer
protection for all 3 pillars thereby providing
an end-to-end confidential computing environment
in the IBM Cloud.
So, how does IBM
provide this level of security?
Well, the Hyper Protect Services leverage
many years of IBM's security and
privacy experience to the Cloud.
To do this, we deploy our services on
special LinuxONE hardware that utilizes
what's known as a Secure Service Container.
This is a protective boundary around the base
operating system, management backend
and application interface to ensure no
access by the unauthorized figures like system
administrators or the cloud providers.
Secure Service Container ensures:
Data Integrity and self-attestation - There
is  tamper protection and verification through
signatures that the packaged software image is
deployed from a trusted source and not
been modified since leaving the vendor.
In case any tamper is detected,
Secure Service Container will not boot that image.
There are several examples of client
segments from financial institutes,
automotive manufacturers to start-ups who are
currently using the Hyper Protect Services
to achieve confidential computing.
Today, we're going to explore one particular
use case, the Digital Assets Platform.
With this use case, clients are tokenizing
and trading assets, similarly to
how the stock market works.
However, the assets aren't shares of a company,
they can range from coins to commodities.
With our digital assets platform,
you have the asset itself,
that is run by a combination of 3 things.
A base technology, Blockchain,
that provides the ledger.
The Wallets, to protect keys.
And Exchanges, or the digital marketplace.
To provide a confidential computing environment
for the Digital Assets Platform, first,
we utilize protected runtimes with Hyper Protect
Virtual Servers to actually run the application.
These run within a Secure Service Container that
automatically encrypts data and provides memory
protection to ensure that no unauthorized
person gets access to secure data.
Next, we work with the Hyper Protect Crypto
Services to utilize the Hardware Security Module,
or HSM, and Key Management Service.
With this technology, built on FIPS 140-2 Level 4
certified hardware, clients can
lock down their storage, backups,
Secure Service Container, and applications.
Finally, we work with other IBM Cloud offerings
to provide backup and storage, also integrated
with Crypto Services, and holistically
locking down the entire environment.
In this way, we protect from
malicious actors in several ways.
They cannot SSH into the boundary, the wallets and
ledgers are stored in Cold Storage, or offline,
with encrypted communications, and the Secure
Service Container is tamper-proof and will prevent
unauthorized access through these back doors.
So, with that example in mind, there
are 2 reasons to choose Hyper Protect
for Confidential Computing:
First, clients maintain complete authority
over their workloads. They have exclusive
control of who sees the data, what happens
to that data and how that data is processed.
Second, client data and applications are
protected from both insider and outsider
threats. There is technical assurance,
not just operational assurance.
We go beyond the confidential computing
environment to protect data at all stages, in
flight, at-rest, and in-use, plus the complete
authority that only comes with IBM Cloud.
With that, thank you for listening to this
brief overview of IBM Cloud Hyper
Protect Services and their role
in the confidential computing environment.
Do not forget to check us out at the links below.